Дорогі одинадцятикласники, вітаю
вас на уроці української літератури.
Мене звати Анастасія Євдокимова.
Я керую промоцією читання в
Українському інституті книги.
Тож поговоримо з вами про читання.
Це просто вражаюче. Тридцять
хвилин пролетіли просто непомітно.
Вже декілька тижнів ми з вами
вивчаємо творчість шістдесятників –
покоління, яке творило
в 60-х роках 20 століття.
Ми згадували вже і про Василя
Симоненка, і про Дмитра Павличка,
і про Миколу Вінграновського.
Сьогодні поговоримо
нарешті про Василя Стуса.
Отже, народився Василь Стус
7 січня 1938 року, але насправді,
ми знаємо що це було 6 січня,
адже мама Василя Стуса прагнула
уникнути Різдва, уникнути цієї дати 6
січня і записала сина на день пізніше.
Народився він в селищі на
Вінниччині і незабаром родина
переїхала в місто Донецьк.
Сьогодні це місто Донецьк,
тоді це було місто Сталіно.
Донецьк було невеличким містечком,
було багато хат, металургійний завод,
навколо якого ці хати розростались.
Як і все покоління шістдесятників,
Василь Стус був «дитиною війни».
Він не просто бачив ІІ Світову
війну, вона безпосередньо
впливала на нього як на особистість.
Він добре запам'ятав зиму
1946-47 років, про що він пізніше
напише у листах до сина.
І власне, ті цитати, які ми
сьогодні будемо бачити на дошці –
це цитати із листів до сина, де Стус
розповідає і пригадує, і переказує
історію становлення себе як особистості.
Коли йому було дев'ять років, вони
будували хату і він згадує про те,
що тато тоді помирав з
голоду, ми пхали тачку,
місили глину, самі будували будинок.
Потім Василь Стус розповідає як
він ходив пасти корів своїх сусідів
для того, аби принести трішки
їжі додому, тому що він розумів,
що хоче нагодувати не
лишесебе, але й маму.
Пізніше Дмитро Стус напише, син
Василя Стуса, власне, до якого і писав
батько листи, «Бідність дозволила
чіткіше самоідентифікуватися:
коли не хочеш втратити власної
гідності, не можна ні дарувати,
ні забувати батьківське горе».
Тож про своїх батьків і,
власне, про історію своєї родини,
Василь Стус не забував
протягом всього життя.
Про любов до читання він
теж писав в листах до сина.
Він писав про ті перші
книжки, які він читав.
Це спогад про те, що він нібито… перша
книжка, яку він взяв в бібліотеці,
це була нібито книжка
ВасиляСтефаника «Кленові листки».
Але насправді, ми розуміємо що
- ні, читати Василь Стус почав
значно раніше, коли
вчились його брати й сестри.
Йому ще не було 6 років, а
він вже навчався читати книжки.
Це була одна з тих небагатьох
розваг, які в них були під час війни.
Про любов до читання в своїх
листах він згадував неодноразово.
Колись він прочитав «Мартіна
Ідена» Джека Лондона,
про що також пише у своїх
листах. І от його це вразило.
Чому? Тому що «… світ мені перевернувся.
Як мучилась людина, а змогла
перевершити всіх, хто купався в молоці!
І все - тяжким трудом».
Саменаголос на літері «у» - трудом.
Це слово є в словнику
української мови і воно означає
тяжку сумлінну працю,
внутрішню роботу над собою.
«… і все солоним кривавим потом»,
тобто не просто все давалось
і Василю Стусу, і героям, які його
приваблювали, і героям, зрештою
ліричних текстів, про яких він писав.
«І вже я був у дев'ятому класі.
І вже мріяв про геологорозвідку,
бо марив мандрами».
Дмитро Стус, син Василя,
пояснює, що вірогідно Василь Стус
трішки прикрашав свою біографію.
Він її припасовував до того, що
потрібно бути людиною, яка відразу,
від початку, з наймолодших років знає
чого вона хоче, яка йде до своєї мети.
Він пише про те, що хотів
мандрувати, його це приваблювало.
Тобто вже з  дитинства Василь Стус знав
про що він мріє, знав чого він хоче.
Так само він захоплювався музикою.
І в сьомому класі батько
подарував йому гітару.
З гітарою Василь Стус провів потім
дуже багато часу, адже саме вправляння,
саме вигравання забирало не лише час,
але й приносило йому
неймовірну насолоду.
І пізніше в інституті було те саме.
Так він згадує, як вперше
прийшов до філармонії
і як його це захопило та здивувало.
«Пам'ятаю, як уперше
пішов до філармонії.
Пам'ятаю як прослухав
цикл лекцій про Бетховена –
всі9 симфоній і чимало концертів.
А які пречудові його
сонати! І яка це була людина!
Все життя - в горі, в
нещасті, в муці - і він -
один проти цілого світу – перемагає!»
Такі постаті захоплювали Василя Стуса,
як зрештою, захоплює він і нас сам.
Історико-філологічний факультет
педагогічного університету –
це місце, куди прийшов
навчатись Василь Стус.
Коли йому було 16 років, він
мріяв  вступити на журналістику
в університет в Києві, але, на жаль,
у 16 років не брали на навчання.
Тому він залишився в рідному
Донецьку, і де отримував фах
не лише філолога українського,
тобто фахівця з української мови
та літератури, але й історика.
Зі спогадів сучасників, Василя Стуса
не задовольняв той рівень навчання,
який він отримував в
університеті, ті викладачі,
він завжди прагнув чогось більшого.
І так «… він найпершим з'являвся в
аудиторії №38, він сідав за першу парту,
відкривав якийсь підручник. У нього
в портфелі завжди було що читати:
Кант, Ніцше, Монтень, Фейєрбах…».
Ми знаємо, що Василь Стус
перекладав, зрештою, Рільке.
Він читав в оригіналі Гете, він
дуже добре знав німецьку мову.
Це така велика цінність для автора
- не лише володіти власною мовою,
але й могти читати інші тексти.
Василь Стус - молодий юний студент,
так він виглядав.
І 1959 року, коли Василь
Стус був ще студентом,
його надрукували в
«Літературній газеті».
Пригадайте, ми говорили вже про це.
Саме в «Літературній газеті» вперше
з’являлись твори і Івана Драча,
і Миколи Вінграновського, і
всіх тих авторів, які належали
до покоління шістдесятників.
Власне в «Літературній газеті»
Василя Стуса надрукували
з передмовою Андрія Малишка.
Що ж написав Андрій
Малишко про Василя Стуса?
Вероніко, прочитайте нам, будь ласка.
«… природа поезії не
любить одноманітності.
Справжній поет,  якого б він не
був діапазону, повинен мати свій,
а не запозичений голос,
свій тембр, фарби і лінії,
своє  розкриттяі зображення
подій, і явищ дійсності».
Таким був Василь Стус.
Він бачив світ по-своєму, він не
намагався бути ні на кого схожим
і в цьому ми переконаємось далі.
Отже, потім після університету
була служба в армії вимушена,
61-го року він повернувся в
місто Донецьк і вчителював.
Був він, звісно, вчителем
української мови і літератури,
хоча тоді в російськомовному
Донецьку це було не так просто,
адже Василю Стусу доводилось
шукати інші методи навчання.
Він читав дітям власні тексти,
він переказував їм різні історії,
він заохочував їх до
вивчення мови і літератури.
Тоді ж він написав лист
до Андрія Малишка аби той
якось вплинув на русифікацію Донбасу.
Він писав, що: «Я вважаю, що доля
Донбасу - це майбутня доля України».
Власне, мабуть, так і є сьогодні.
Зрештою Василь Стус
вступив в аспірантуру
Академії Наук і переїхав до Києва.
Це було важливо для нього,
для всіх шістдесятників,
адже саме тут в Києві він
подружився з Іваном Світличним.
Іваном Світличним –
літературознавцем,який не просто знав
всіх шістдесятників,
він сам був одним з тих,
хто займались культурним життям столиці.
Тож саме Іван Світличний
увів Василя Стуса в ці кола.
1964 року поет здавав збірку,
свою першу збірку «Круговерть»
у видавництво «Молодість».
І коли він з цією збірочкою їхав
у метро, він випадково познайомився
із своєю майбутньою
дружиною Валентиною Попелюх.
Власне, про інтимну лірику ми
поговоримо сьогодні трішки більше,
її почитаємо – лірику, присвячену
дружині, матері його дітей.
1965 рік - прем'єра фільму Сергія
Параджанова «Тіні забутих предків».
Ми вже згадували з вами про цю дату,
адже саме тоді українська
інтелігенція повстала,
вона встала в залі під час
прем'єри фільму і сказала про те,
що вона незадоволена тими арештами,
тими репресіями, які відбуваються.
Адже саме того ранку Василь Стус
дізнався, що його близького друга
Івана Світличного заарештували.
Так після цієї події Василь
Стус став неблагонадійним,
за ним почали слідкувати.
Творчий доробок Василя
Стуса до 1972 року.
Чому? Тому що 1972 року
життя Василя Стуса зміниться,
адже його заарештують.
Але про це ми поговоримо
вже наступного разу,
сьогодні ми зупинимось на
першому періоді його творчості.
Це збірка «Круговерть» 1964-го
року, збірка «Зимові дерева» 1970-го.
Я хочу наголосити, що жодна з цих
збірок не вийшла в Радянському Союзі.
Тож «Зимові дерева» поширювались
самвидавом як і решта творів,
які передавались за кордон, які
тиражувались і були знані там.
Збірка «Веселий цвинтар»
1971-го року і ґрунтовна розвідка
«Феномен доби (сходження на
голгофу слави)» про Павла Тичину.
Якою є подібність між Павлом
Тичиною і Василем Стусом
ми поговоримо теж трішки пізніше.
От давайте зафіксуємо
для себе цю розвідку
і зафіксуємо для себе такий текст.
Я хотіла би запросити Вероніку
прочитати інтимну лірику Василя Стуса
з першої збірки
«Круговерть» ще 1964-го року.
Яким він був цей ліричний Василь Стус?
Ще до арешту, ще до всіх неприємностей,
коли він відчував себе вільною людиною?
В понеділок зустрівся з дівчиною.
У вівторок — поцілував.
За першим разом — образилась.
За другим — мовчала.
В середу освідчувався в коханні.
Доводив довго-предовго,
коли четвер пропливав,
як козацький байрак — порогами.
В п'ятницю не прийшов на побачення.
У суботу згадав,
але не прийшов і в неділю.
Цікаво.
Вчителька: Про що цей текст?
Як змінюються ці почуття?
Як змінюються ці
стосунки протягом тижня?
Змінюються стрімголов.
Вчителька: Стрімголов.
Стрімголов – це як?
Це занадто швидко.
Потім зустрів, потім
поцілував, вона образилась,
вона мовчала, а в середу освідчувався
в коханні, а в четвер пропливав,
як козацький байрак – порогами.
Це як? Як ми собі це уявляємо?
Ну напевно вже з високо піднятою
головою. Так, що може й не помітити.
Як козацький човен.
Він оминав всі перешкоди,
він піднімався, опускався,
був впевнений у своєму
русі. Але в п'ятницю …
Вероніка Селега: Все змінилося.
Все змінилось так, як найчастіше
буває в житті, він зрозумів,
що, напевно, ця дівчина і
ці стосунки не для нього.
Мабуть. Ми не знаємо точно.
Ще один текст, це також інтимна лірика,
присвячений дружині Василя
Стуса Валентині Попелюх.
Це тій, з якою вони
познайомились у метро,
коли він їхав зі своєю
першою збірочкою «Круговерть».
Прочитайте, будь ласка.
І не те, щоб жити — більше:
споконвіку б — без розлуки.
До віків і після віку —
це — любов. Оце — вона!
І не те, щоб знову — «з Богом!»
І не те, щоб — «чорту в зуби!»
Ні. Не те. А тихо-тихо:
ані пестощів, ні ласк.
Тільки б так: вона — як щогла,
в ріст Великої Дзвіниці
(велич гнітиться доземно,
ниць сягає до небес).
Не дзвонар ти. І не Шедель,
а відвідувач, закоханий
Не говори — по вуха:
геть поверх людських голів…
Це — любов. Вона, як жінка
крутостегна. Це — початок твій.
Це вечір. Смерк ласкавий.
Це перерва, як прорив.
І не те, щоб більше — (жити б!)
І не те, щоб жити — (більше!)
…до віків і після віку —
перемрієш — тільки й того.
Отже, про що текст, присвячений дружині?
Який він є? Як Василь Стус
до своєї дружини ставиться?
Цей вірш вже наповнений ніжністю
і тут вже така глибока пристрасть.
Чому ніжністю? Чому … де ми
відчуваємо, в яких словах,
можливо, цю ніжність або в яких образах?
Сказати так, що в конкретних словах
- напевно ні, але загальний настрій –
ну він дуже ніжний, просто
підносить ту людину, якій присвячено.
Про якусь таку любов?
Вероніка Селега: Так.
Яка є особливою? І
напевне буває лише раз.
Вчителька: Мені дуже подобається,
що любов - вона як жінка
Крутостегна. Вперше бачу
це слово, якщо чесно.
Яка це – крутостегна?
Крутостегна? Це …
Вчителька: Круті стегна … пишна.
Так, пишна.
Пишна жінка. Любов, вона теж така
- пишна і розкішна.
На нашій молодій воді
тепер ані човна.
Чадіють пасма молоді —
то бариться весна.
Ще герметичний стогін верб
не влився в жили віт,
а вже пожовклий стовбур стерп,
глухий, як динаміт.
Як закорковане вино,
беріз шумує сік,
він чує небо, ніби дно,
а землю — гирлом рік.
Іще на ранньому лужку
не кільчиться моріг
(був виплів стежечку витку,
а душ — не поберіг
рахманно пагорбами ріль
води — рахманно — вис
малий метелик, наче біль
малий на крилах ніс —
рахманно — пагорбами ріль
він ріс і даленів...
Під ятаган татарських зіль
сумний наш човен плив
і — переспраглий носорог —
біг місяць молодий.
Він плеса бив — торох-торох!
аби добуть води.
На чорній молодій воді —
ані тобі човна.
Лиш миче пасмуги руді
задумана весна.
Така грайлива пісня.
Вероніка Селега: Неймовірно.
Грайлива пісенька і здавалося б
- де ж тут, де ж тут любов,
де ж тут почуття? Чи вони тут є взагалі?
Вероніка Селега: В настрої.
Так щиро ти можеш
говорити тільки з людиною
і промовляти до людини, яку ти кохаєш.
Василь Стус і його
дружина пані Валентина.
Це день їхнього одруження,
так вони виглядали. Ще одна.
Мовчиш, як покинена вагітна?
Мовчиш, як бомба? Мовчиш?
Думаєш — од чекання розтрісну?
Думаєш — збожеволію?
Надаремне, любов моя.
Надаремне, тюрмо моя.
Надаремне все, зненавидо.
Надаремне, кохана.
Я тебе не сльозою — ждатиму.
Я тебе кулаками — ждатиму.
Кулаками — у глупу поніч,
кулаками — в подушку.
Не пиши. Не відповідай.
Проклинаю. Цілую. Мовчки.
Задушився чеканням — мовчки.
Кулаками — в подушку.
Вероніка Селега: Різко.
Різко?
Різко.
Вчителька: Як це?
Але дуже пронизливо.
Вчителька: Про що цей текст?
Вероніка Селега: Це такий текст,
вибудуваний виключно на почуттях.
На почуттях і вигуках. Народилося
почуття – виплеснулося в слово,
народилося нове слово. І ось
таким чином, як … тому дуже різко,
бо думки перескакують з однієї на іншу.
А кулаками в подушку – це
про любов чи про ненависть?
Це про злість від, напевно,
нерозділеного почуття або неможливості
бачитися разом, або від
неможливості бути поруч.
Вчителька: Невідомо.
Але прекрасно.
Є ліричний герой і ми можемо
уявляти що з ним відбувалося.
І не асоціювати його з автором,
що для нас теж дуже важливо –
коли біографія діяча, власне - його
творчість, вони все одно рухаються
паралельно і ми собі уявляємо
– це якісь паралельні процеси.
Ще один текст, на мою
суб'єктивну думку – найліричніший.
Я дуже … я запрошую вас
почитати, насолодитись.
Вероніка Селега: Якщо
ваш найулюбленіший,
то тут мені треба більше
добавити почуттів. Так.
Коли я один-однісінький
серед зелених снігів Приуралля,
коли в казармі порожньо
серед ліжок і пірамід,
коли я стовбичу на цьому
днювальному місточку
самотній — на обидві земні півкулі,
як холодна колодочка караульного ножа,
Коли така далека-далека
така миттєва, потойбічна майже,
як спалах, вихоплений з ракетниці,
швидко згасаєш на спиртовому полум’ї
синюватого, майже непомітного
уральського морозу,
Заклинаю, немов клинок!
Віддалена від мене на
сімсот тридцять чотири дні,
на сімсот тридцять чотири «здрастуй»,
скажи, що ти мене любиш.
Тільки скажи «люблю».
Коли я один-однісінький
Одне-єдине, кругле, вологе соковите,
як плід біля вишневої кісточки,
червоне слово.
І я почую тебе.
І я радісно посміхнуся тобі,
нехай навіть засіпається моє підборіддя,
враз розм’якле,
як губи доброго притомленого коня.
Скажи — тільки одне слово!
Я нікому його не показуватиму.
Коли ж до казарми повернуть друзі —
я заховаю це слово аж під борлаком
і, нахиливши голову,
розглядатиму
набряклу колодочку
караульного ножа.
«Коли я один-однісінький».
Ліричний герой чекає на
зустріч з своєю коханою,
яке відбудеться не скоро, тому що
між ними 734 дні, 734 «здрастуй»,
яке вони не скажуть одне одному.
Але є так само червоне, соковите,
як плід біля вишневої
кісточки, слово люблю.
Які почуття викликає цей текст?
Скажемо так – найінтимніші. Так,  бо
тут любов кричить крізь самотність.
Ми тут тільки вгадуємо
наскільки теплим є це почуття,
всеоб’ємлючим, наскільки заповнює
всю душу автора і … Неймовірно!
Вчителька: Дякую!
Я хотіла би запропонувати
послухати голос самого Василя Стуса,
адженаприкінці 60-х років він
записав декілька своїх текстів,
які потім пізніше КДБ,
звісно, забрали під час обшуку,
але їх вдалось реставрувати,
відтворити, вони існують як аудіозаписи.
Тож давайте послухаємо як свій
текст читає сам Василь Стус.
Текст твору ви бачите на екрані.
Запрошую послухати ще один
уривок, вже з більшої поеми.
Але – скільки почуттів.
Яким є цей текст?
Прошу звернути увагу на те, що
текст подано з вибраного видання,
з видання, яке власне,
впорядкував син Василя Стуса Дмитро
і цей текст дещо відрізняється від
того варіанту, який читає Василь Стус.
Декілька окремих слів різняться.
Ми розуміємо, що така відмінність
можлива, ми її допускаємо
цю відмінність окремих
слів, окремих читань.
За роком рік росте твоя тюрма,
за роком рік підмур'я в землю грузне,
і за твоїм жалінням заскорузлим,
за безголів'ям - просвітку нема.
Живеш - і жди. Народжуйся - і жди.
Жди - перед сконом. Жди – у домовині.
Не назирай - літа збігають згінні
без цятки неба й кухлика води.
Ти весь - на бережечку самоти,
присмоктаний до туги, ніби равлик,
од вибухлої злості занепалий,
боїшся межі болю осягти.
А світ весь витих, витух, відпалав,
не вгамувавши вікової спраги.
Він висмоктав із тебе всю одвагу,
лишив напризволяще і прокляв.
«Двоє слів читачеві» - це передмова
до збірки «Зимові дерева»
1970 року і, власне, я хочу
запросити вас після уроку виконати
домашнє завдання і прочитати ці
кілька слів, тому що вони про маму,
про слово, про інститутські роки.
Воно вбирає всю ту мудрість,
якою хоче поділитись Василь Стус
перед цією збіркою поетичною
аби налаштувати на читання.
Отже, сьогодні ми поговорили
про шістдесятника Василя Стуса,
ми поговорили про його ранню
творчість, про творчість до 1972 року.
Зокрема почитали інтимну поезію,
почули голосВасиля Стуса.
І запрошую вас наступного
уроку підготуватись,
взяти збірочку Василя Стуса
і ми продовжимо наше читання.
Дякую вам за урок. Я
чую продзвенів дзвінок.
Це означає, що нам пора завершувати.
Гарного вам дня. Ідіть на перерву.
Дякую!
Це був неймовірний досвід,
особливо зважаючи на те,
що моєю вчителькою української
літератури сьогодні була Анастасія –
це експертка Українського
інституту книги.
І Василь Стус, ну один
з найулюбленіших діячів –
в цілому, в українській
історії для мене особисто.
В Донецьку.
Перша збірка Василя Стуса
називається «Круговерть».
І до речі, при нагоді хочу
добавити про такий проект,
як «Живі Письменники»,
яким займається Тетяна Стус.
І це зараз в карантинний
період ідеальний час,
коли можна з дітьми дошкільного
і молодшого шкільного віку
опанувати програму живих класиків.